zach playsack ready to go tim anderson
taking his time as he steps in at home
plate
swinging in a miss tim anderson goes
down swinging one away
he went back-to-back change-ups one was
upstairs this one here
had great downward movement down below
the strike zone he gets anderson to
swing and miss here in chicago last week
moncado was hitting
fourth in the lineup coming in here now
he's moved to the number three hole
swings at the 3-1 pitch and lifts it
high in the ear to shallow left in comes
andy rosario and the white sox go one
two three
carlos rodon back to the hill against
the cleveland indians
you mentioned johnny vandermeer trying
to go full johnny vandermeer
back-to-back no-hitters you look at the
lineup terry francona is running out
it is the very same lineup that carlos
no hit
here it is swing and a miss he got him
that was a very
late cut by hernandez on a fastball one
away
and now a 3-0 count on franmill reyes
runner
at first two down no score first inning
the pitch
inside back reyes off the plate for ball
four
eddie rosario they'll go lefty lefty
here in the first
rosario to center luis robert got it
getting over two stranded clean up
hitter jose abreu d8
tonight big bouncer to short albed
rosario
[Music]
makes a good throw one now mean mercedes
coming to the plate and
see that oh that's not gonna feel good
on a cold night he's all of that let's
see uh where this got him
i think right on the front foot nobody's
in a hurry to come out and check on him
oh right off the top of the actually get
out there he's just trying to get some
feeling he said i'll be all right he
might have hit that right off the big
bone on the top
yeah i'm sorry he did one two pitch weak
ground ball
and mercedes lumbering down the line say
what he did a nice job getting down the
line
two down he has money grand all to the
plate i'm a little surprised he's not
catching today
i am too to be honest with you right
well one two three on the white sox zach
blisak appears to be locked in tonight
one down for mr imperfect yeah i kind of
worry about him
not that he's going to get hit on the
shoe again but he had a couple of really
good at bats against carla
struck him out high fastball two gone
now they're starting to be a little life
on that fastball that was up to 95.
that's the
hardest fast ball he's thrown tonight
chang playing first base
topped up second base madrigal first
time through the order for carlos rodon
three walks no hits
robert vaughn and madrigal against zach
plezak
another breaking ball this one yanked
toward the left field corner it's going
to get down for a hit
robert on his way to second and he will
get in
standing that is a lead double by louise
robert
robert at third one and two again
chopper to third no play for ramirez
coming home and madrigal drives in a run
with a ground ball with two strikes
and it's one nothing sucks here is
anderson 3-2
timothy drive center field luke blow at
the wall
bring him home two nothing socks
pasta for tim anderson and a two-nothing
lead
this is a change-up you can only throw
the same pitch
to tim anderson a number of times before
he figures it out for tim anderson
third home run and third run driven in
top of the order jordan luplow
into the motion the 2-2 swung in
and belted to deep left away
back gone and jordan luplow
has hit his fifth home run
boy what a start for luplow a no
doubt about it bound to left and the
indians are on the board
carlos rodon will not throw back to back
no hitters
and he's given up his first run of the
year
in this his third start the two down
freddie rosario
swinging a miss strike three yeah zero
chance on the slider
so bye-bye eddie jose jose-d-h he
bounced to short
01 to jose that falls drilled to left
field
he came in with a fastball and got
crushed it's gone
what's the one he missed let's see if
you're looking for one at bat
that could turn things around he got two
inside fastballs the first time
up well hitters have memories also
gleesack apparently felt that jose was
going to swing through those all night
long
jose figured you know what i saw two the
first time up maybe i'll see another
and if i do i'm gonna hit it out of the
park for his third home run
there's the inside fastball that is a
blast on a very cold night in cleveland
josh naylor will be the batter
and that's catcher's interference on
granddaughter so two on
nobody out on roberto perez who struck
out his first time up
is the batter down low ball and the
bases are loaded shang
first problem is he got a loop blown
next one two
he struck him out locked him up on a
slider and there is your strikeout now a
ground ball would do the trick three and
two bases loaded
struck him out again upstairs
to god cesar hernandez the batter
cesar hernandez off the glove of montana
and they'll get one coming around third
and josh naylor is a dead duck he ran
right into the third out of the inning
yeah i mean an easy out if you watch
that's a great play by anderson
you know mike sauerbos pointing at the
base he's pointing at the base to stay
there
he didn't pick him up he didn't either
hear him look at he's pointing right
there stay
and josh has just got his head going
home robert advances to third on the
play but now there's two down
two one back to please sack with a
terrific play
and the pitcher robs anderson of a
potential hit to end the inning one on
for
johan monkana go on
into right center that's down up the
alleyway
eaton's racing by third he's coming home
throw to the plate is
well short and the sox lead four to two
moncada
drives in run number four single double
run in nobody out abreu
smokes that ball that was a miss on a
slider and jose's got himself a single
to drive in moncada
jose's two for his last two and the
socks
are cooking he has money granddaugh
batting left-handed
grondal drills it right field side
naylor's back he has no chance
two run home run for yaz what a very
cold night
where the ball isn't traveling this high
fastball leaves the yard sox have
rediscovered the long ball today that's
the third home run of the night that's
ty for the season high
and a nice lead in cleveland yasmani
thought right away that that ball was
gone
abreu a 458 foot
solo homer to left tonight and an rbi
single last inning
oh that's a long fly ball deep left
field and abreu
has another second home run for jose
abreu this is one of the things that
we've been waiting for and jose kept
saying don't worry
it's coming don't worry i'm a slow
starter but i'm going to have the
numbers
tonight everything has come up jose
brandmail reyes the matter
one for two with a single and a watch
big hole on the right side and fred mill
finds it
and they're going to wave the runner
around third even though luplow had
stopped
momentarily he scores he didn't touch
complete i don't think he touched the
player
and he is going to coyly walk back and
make sure he touches it
it's like he heard you andre yeah well
he never touched i don't think he
touched him
josh naylor to the plate smoked a deep
left
garcia back it is off the wall and
scoring his friend mill reyes
and in the second with a two out rbi
double the other way is
josh naylor cody hoyer
lets it fly and perez whacks one into
center that'll be an rbi
single around third heading home is
naylor
roberto perez with his ninth run batted
in
so here's the closer hendricks hoping he
can make quick work of bowers here and
to third johan monkana and this is
finally the end of the line tonight liam
hendricks a three-pitch
save and the sox do win eight to five in
cleveland